absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
uh what a less yes yes yes yes we
finally have a female Legend on the
podcast and what a guest to start she's
the two-time Rugby World Cup winner with
the black ferns most cap black Fern of
all time and she's also been voted the
best women's player in New Zealand and
the world she's also one of the real
characters of the woman's game it is the
great Kendra Cox Edge welcome
thanks for having me uh Jimmy thanks for
the call up making it onto the water lad
podcast I'm excited about it we will
have to change that name I feel what do
you think I I Googled what what's the
equivalent of lead and female for a
female and it comes up as less I also
got told less is a little bit offensive
so I wasn't quite sure what to call it
but how do you feel about waterless
yeah well I don't know about that either
I would have to ever ever think
um but I quite like how you called it
what a lot that's that's that's all
right just if you're going to mix it up
have some females on here too it
shouldn't matter what the what the old
podcast is called
um but yeah perfect I like that what a
lad we stay on
perfect and exciting times having our
first female guests yeah it's pretty
exciting to be the first um
got me forward to I've heard a couple of
podcasts with Richie Moana and then in
the past so I'm looking forward to
having a chat with you awesome stuff
looking forward to it and obviously
you're freshly off becoming the most
capped black Fern of all time
um hell of an achievement what was what
was that like for you
oh it's massive um I think rolling into
last week probably like 48 Hours you
know I guess the day before the game The
Day of the game and after
um it was huge huge for me
um I still feel like I'm not sure if
it's fully kicked in yet
um but now it's pretty exciting to lead
into that and you know you kind of come
in you've got a whole new coaching group
you're not sure what they're thinking so
I was like am I even gonna be playing
um you know you kind of go through all
these thoughts on your head uh so when
that team first got selected
um you know I rang the family and I said
hey you know you might want to come up
uh up from the necky to watch this game
um you know because I knew it was kind
of coming up but um yeah it's so surreal
um we'll just can't really describe it
um it's pretty special you know 16 years
on the side
um and yeah to finally get out there and
achieve it
um which was pretty special for me and
my family yeah 16 years it's been some
career for sure and you guys are
building towards this big Rugby World
Cup later in the year on home turf
exciting times for for the black ferns
how's the camp looking
Cam's looking really really good
um obviously coming off in the air tour
and then and then going through the
review but we've worked really hard to
go through processes to leave that
behind we had to move on pretty quickly
and and fast as well um you know so we
had to kind of get their momentum moving
and um you know we've got got a few new
coaching group come on board and
um it was massive for us as players that
we had to move forward with the Pinnacle
event
um so it's it's awesome the group's
awesome there's a lot of young young
girls I think in the in the game in the
weekend the most kept forward was five
caps I think so wow it's pretty
inexperienced at the moment
um but yeah it's um that's pretty
awesome having having likes of Smithy uh
Wesley Clarken and then Whitney Hansen
on board and then having Ellen bunting
there as well which has helped me a lot
as a leader yeah you talk about that
coaching group what if what have they
added what's especially in particular
Wayne Smith what's he added to the group
foreign
[Music]
a great coach as we know he's he's world
class and
um for us he's I guess he's allowing the
girls to express themselves he wants to
see the girls make mistakes
um because if he thinks if you're not
making mistakes then you're not you know
you're not challenging yourself and
we're not playing the right game that we
want to play
um he's got a lot got you know up and up
in his head and for me as an experienced
player I'm trying to draw that out as
much as possible
um he's you know he randomizes training
our trainings are all quite random and
he's big on you know being adaptable and
us as players adapting to that so now
there's a lot of a lot of things he's
you know he's getting into his dance
moves with the team
um I think he's kind of getting used to
coach coaching females again
um he's yeah we have a dance that we
sign off training with
um he always comes up to me every now
and then he's like how do you reckon I'm
doing kinch you know any feedback do you
reckon I'm going all right and I'm like
right you're on this Circle doing it
that's a start
um but um the culture he's kind of
started to create already is is pretty
awesome but he needs to know the
difference between his left and right a
link to help with his dance moves
oh that's classic so
um how does that sort of compare to last
year um obviously you mentioned you
didn't quite get the results that you
wanted but what did you sort of put that
down to looking back on reflection was
it a culture thing was it
um yeah what what would you put it down
to
I think for us um the culture was
awesome last year as well um there was a
good group of girls we had no you know
zero issues off the park um you know we
actually trained pretty well we just we
just couldn't put their performance out
on the park and
um you know I'm not going to use the
excuses of covert um you know in terms
of the fitness level of the side there
was one thing that was wasn't you know
up to the to International standard
um and then I probably put it down to
just the lack of footy
um over the last couple of years and a
lack of footage at a you know not just
at an international level but at the top
of the international game you know so
always going over there and playing
England and France was always going to
be challenging for the side
um so it was it was it was a challenging
tour
um and it was yeah our set piece was it
was tough at times too we just didn't
get it you know we didn't build any good
platforms to to let our electric backs
um you know free up and play
um but I think from there sometimes
you've got to go through some tough
stuff to to come out dinner here and we
look back now and I mean we're not going
to know until World Cup but you know I
think there's things that have happened
that are probably been the best for the
side um a lot of different little
changes within the group and all that
kind of stuff so I feel like we're on a
really good uh Road at the moment
um and we just got to make sure we just
keep challenging ourselves and putting
our performance out on the park did you
see those results kind of coming or were
they a complete shock to you because
obviously
um from my point of view I definitely
didn't see those big scores coming I
thought over there you guys would have
been a lot more competitive potentially
would have I would have backed you guys
to be winning those games so did you
sort of see that from the from the
inside out
now it probably blindsided us as players
too to be honest Jimmy it was um you
know I went over there going this is
going to be awesome can't wait to play
again you know I'm sure we'll go well
looked at some of the you know look at
their footage and kind of knew they were
going to be good um they're going to be
tough they always are
um but then just yeah getting out there
in that first first game you know you're
kind of like oh [ __ ] you know losses
didn't go too well um but never thought
we'd go over there and lose four games
and that was really hard people to
swallow for me for someone who's been
around for for a long time and we
haven't lost you know I haven't lost
many games in the black Jersey
um so that was really really challenging
for for someone not just for me but
probably for most of the group
um with a lot of girls on debut so some
of them had never won obviously at the
end of that tour never won on the black
Jersey so that's what was important for
us um leading into the game last week
too or even for me at the back of my
mind I was like man we've got to get a
get a win on The Jersey you know we've
got to get a win back in the Jersey not
just for not just for the the new
players but for the country and and um
you know with the World Cup we need to
get the the public in behind us yeah and
I feel like the public is getting behind
you and um it's going to be exciting
times when we get to that Rugby World
Cafe
yeah yeah we can't wait like even far
out the weather was so crap in the
weekend it was just so much rain I don't
think I've ever played a lot I mean you
might have played you know a club game
and that type of weather or that type of
field but um not International test
building and the crowd came out you know
umbrellas and all
um they were you know and they're a nice
vocal crowd too and there's nothing that
Bates playing at home in front of your
family it's it's bloody awesome yeah
bring on the Rugby World Cup looking
forward to it but as always I do want to
go to back to the start like I do with
all my guests um hear about your
upbringing um how you got into footy so
give us a rundown
yeah all right it's uh got to think back
at the memory event going back a few
years now Jimmy but um yeah we've been
playing rugby for 30 30 years this year
so um I started playing rugby when I was
four
um yeah so been been playing for yeah 30
consecutive years
um I'm from tamanaki from the Nike so
grew up there I've got twin sister two
older sisters my mum and dad
um I did a bit of tap dancing with my
sister
um as you can tell I'm quite high energy
and I annoyed my sister and the old in
the old dance class so mum was like Matt
yeah you get you know you're gonna go
down and go hang out with one of our
family friends so mum shut me off with
one of my family friends and they were
going down to a rugby training and
basically make picked up a ball
um and just never looked back that was
my start of my Rugby rugby Journey yeah
um you know obviously played a long time
with the boys
um all the way through up until I went
to high school I went continue from us
girls so all through those Junior grades
that just play with the boys and because
I was from a small town outside of
taranaki or Kato and um you know they
when you're in a small community the the
boys become my brothers you know they
they looked after me um the club looked
after me
um you know I was well looked after and
that's what made my Rugby I guess
probably quite easy and I had the
support from my family my mum and dad
you know I guess back then you know not
many girls played at all
um and even in the necky I think there's
two or three of us that were were
playing at the time and for mum and dad
to allow me to continue to play and
enjoy it you know so I'm pretty grateful
that they allowed me to do that and
that's always pretty cool bring out the
Milestone the other day are they pretty
proud of that and it was a good
opportunity for me to thank them for
what they have done for me
um as well
um but yeah from the mxnd from with
girls high school played school girls
rugby there I'm lucky enough that my
school had rugby a lot of them a lot of
them don't so we're pretty strong we won
out the tanaki school girls competition
most years we used to play up against
Sacred Heart who were pretty challenging
and they played representative with
tanaki secondary school girls then they
had a Hurricane's tournament they'd
sometimes be a paper team and then other
times would be
um you know would actually be a team and
play play a couple of games a majority
of the time was a paper team
and then I moved here to the mighty
Christchurch uh in in 2007 I went down
to Lincoln University got awarded a
cricket scholarship because I played
Cricket as well that's true
um yeah yeah so I got ordered a cricket
scholarship
um little did they know I was gonna play
rugby as well
um got a bit of a
you've got whatever that's left on the
hand for doing that uh and then made the
Canterbury Canterbury women's team and
then from that year I made the black
ferns so
um yeah 19 years old when I when I
debuted but yeah it's still yeah it's
bizarre as bizarre to think back to how
it all kind of panned out but yeah for
me I had a really good upbringing
um and I wasn't a huge
I don't enjoy school
um it wasn't you know I kind of went
there to eat my lunch and play sport but
as I got through the older years of high
school you know you start to think about
what you're going to do and then I
obviously got ordered at Lincoln
University scholarship so I went down
and studied a bachelor of recreational
management and Sport at Lincoln
um which is you know which was pretty
cool for someone who didn't really enjoy
School managed to work hard really hard
and get a degree and then you know make
the black friends uh and also made the
New Zealand a cricket side to the side
that sits under the white ferns the same
year so I kind of had to choose between
them
wow that is that is such a cool story um
love how you got into it so were you
always um really good as a as a young as
a young kid did you compete with the
boys were you still one of the best
yeah I was always told that um we used
to have a few moves based around me
because I think the opposition never
thought that it would they'd give it to
the girl so um no I used to I've always
been halfbacks away mate so always just
absolutely loved it and you know used to
I mean I'm not going to say I was
awesome because I don't think we do that
as kiwis but
um you know I loved it out there and and
um scored a few tries
um and just yeah the boys just used to
used to give me the ball I remember
having this move from a line out so we'd
throw it in and I'd be standing like in
a half back position and it'll just
throw it back down to me and I'll just
be sprinting down the tram lines
um so I remember scoring a few tries
doing that I see that at the Rugby World
Cup
okay watch out
it'd be like the Tony Woodcock move in
the final Tony Woodcock yeah we're
talking about that the other day
actually
because I assigned to them I was like
when are we going to do a line out
special that has the halfback involved
you know no one's ever gonna expect it
oh I save it for the final don't give
too many Clues away yeah no we don't
want to do that
and you mentioned your Cricket
um so how'd you go at Cricket you
obviously were pretty good at Cricket to
get your scholarship
um better bowler I started mostly as a
bowler
um and then uh so all through school and
then they made the Central District
Hines
um and the taranaki women's team and and
then through my career just store Bowl I
was pretty I probably set at school
probably said on about third or fourth
better
um and then later on with the central
districts with the with the city Hines
um it was probably around eight or nine
just coming at the end I was a bit of a
pinch header I always got caught
um I didn't really know how to score
around slowly
um so I used to get caught a lot uh Amy
Amy Mason who used to Amy Watkins now
played with her and she was she used to
score rounds pretty quickly too so I
kind of used to be like Oh I'm not here
to muck around I'm headed I'm here to
hit fours or sixes
um so I tend to get caught a lot on the
boundary uh or call that slips just
trying to give it a good heck but um I
guess towards the end of the cricket I
actually ended up opening the bedding
um so I kind of taught myself to slowly
score run
um and just hold my Wicket so yeah and
then just slowly became a little bit of
an all-rounder really
they need to get you involved in that
black Clash
yeah well I played the year I played the
first year of it when I was down yeah
down in Christchurch yeah and we've got
Ted Ted's in our environment so I've
been um Roofing into them about about
dropping me I was like you dropped me I
never got a phone call after the first
year
um but he reckons he's gonna get me back
so I'll hold him to it I'll see some
boundaries that'll be good stuff so what
made you chose what made you choose
um rugby over Cricket in the end
um I think you know a lot of people can
ask me and I think for me it's probably
around you know Cricket is a long time
it takes up all your day like at six
hours basically all up three hours
bedding three hours in the field
um and I think by the time because I
played for at such a young age and all
the way through and played women's at a
high level at 15.
um I probably just got a little stud to
get a little bit probably sick of it
um you know even though I did enjoy it
but rugby is just you know it's 80
minutes it's I'm a half back I'm
touching the ball every you know every
few seconds so I think that's probably
what ended up making my decision around
that
um I do sit back and and reflect to
wonder what I would have been like if I
chose cricket and where I would be if I
had chosen Cricket I'm never gonna know
um but yeah probably that's probably the
main reason was just rugby was was all
go at the time and I was just absolutely
loving it okay and then you mentioned uh
making the black ferns at just 19 years
old
um must have been pretty crazy what was
it like going into that environment for
the first time and how do you find out
obviously it's not all over Sky TV the
big announcement but how so how do you
find out
yeah so for for me I remember finding
out pretty clearly I was in in the Halls
at at Lincoln uni and
um I got this got this phone call just I
was like oh this is a random number I
made a few of my mates just hanging
around
um and the dorms here you know and the
Halls um and then they rang me to say
that I had um it was a warlock Taylor
actually uh rang me and said that I'd
I'd made the black Fern Squad and you
know when you're young and that age and
the black friends weren't really known a
lot um like I knew they were there I'd
watch them a fair few times
um in 2006 at their world cup and stuff
but I never and I've always wanted to
play for New Zealand but then you know I
just kind of rocked out played
Canterbury rugby and then just got this
phone call to say hey you've made the
you made the black friends or you're
coming into into Camp
um and that's out kind of found out and
I just remember being in a bit of shock
and I think my mates were crying more
than what I was
um so it's pretty pretty cool pretty
cool Wireless there so we found out back
then but um and then I remember rocking
in and you know the likes of Anna
Richards and Victoria Highway and Casey
Robinson and
um you know there's some absolute
Legends of the game and I was you know I
was quite obviously been a halfback
quite a talkative person but I just
remember coming in and I just didn't say
boo for like the first two years
yeah and I was pretty
it was pretty daunting coming in but um
you know they took me under their wing
uh looked after me and you know Emma
Jensen was another legend of the game at
half back and worked alongside her
um you know for for a few years and
um but I just remember coming in and
just felt a little bit like didn't want
to put my foot wrong
um especially at 19 years and years old
so yeah no it was it was pretty it was
pretty special at the same time and then
I got to make my debut in wanganui
against Australia I remember getting
what two and a half minutes off the
bench ran on
um I think I just about I was about to
put the ball on the wrong side of the
scrum actually
I I ran on and hit the ball and I was
like hang on a minute I'm on the wrong
side so I had to quickly scoot around to
the other side
um because I think I was like winter
kind of put like just about to put it in
I was like what the hell where's the
hooker's foot like so um scooted around
the other side the rift didn't even tell
me either
but um like two and a half minutes it
felt like it was about 10 seconds it
went that quick yeah it always does
ain't coming off the bed
but um yeah
is there any sort of like um Traditions
or initiations you do in the black ferns
like for a 19 year old coming in how are
you treated no it's yeah no it's it's um
I mean it's all about you know I guess
having it coming into another
environment that you
and I think the main thing
is that we had a lot of like standards
and and protocols that you had to kind
of live by coming into the side and if
you broke one of those protocols um it
was pretty ruthless in terms of yeah
yeah I guess you call it a consequence
or a punishment even though I don't like
those two words um and you you do it a
bit different these days but um you know
if yeah if you were late or
um you know you forgot your kit or you
left something behind
um you went into the the ring of fire
and you you pulled a card out and each
card had a little bit of like
um you know like a punishment whatever
that was it might have been you know you
had to dress inside out or wear your
skins you know full skins to breakfast
and and all that kind of stuff but um so
you I never wanted to put a flot wrong I
was like oh my gosh like just just put
my head down do what I needed to do
um because it was pretty scary or
singing a song or singing the answer or
something and there's a 19 year old you
know like that's daunting um so I didn't
have that was pretty good yeah I think
there was one time I mean I've never
been late in this team um it's something
that I I just I just likeness as a
non-negotiable
um yeah but there's one time I um I left
my room key I think on the table and
someone picked it up and when I went
into the ring of fire I was like oh my
God please don't get the singing one
please don't get the singing One
um but I had to wear the full the full
skins to breakfast so it wasn't too bad
but never again I didn't want to put a
foot wrong that's for sure
so how does that how does that look now
in terms of those sort of um punishments
wait we just got
let's try to try and create a a really
good environment where everyone kind of
feels safe and and loves it and I guess
it's around creating that high
performance environment so
um girls come in and knowing that you
know that you need to be where you need
to be or have what you need to have so
we don't necessarily have that that
anymore
um we're just working through a bit of a
process with a new coaching group now
around small things like that so we
haven't got anything necessarily locked
in yet
um but the the girls have been pretty
good actually
um so that's what makes it because you
don't have a punishment every time it's
a bit tough obviously as we know with
the new generation coming through you've
got to be a bit nicer to them because I
say to them I was like man when I came
in as a 19 year old holy heck yeah back
in my day yeah
I never thought I'd be the person saying
that but
you've obviously had an incredible
career
um so many amazing achievements so many
big games any sort of games that really
stand out for you as
um career highlights yeah there's always
there's always a few that kind of stick
out to you and you know mine would
probably the one iron in terms of a
whole year 2015 was a really cool year
um we just come off that 2014 World Cup
and we weren't successful we lost to
Ireland and the um and the round robin
which kicked us out because there was no
like uh quarterfinals or anything back
then so
um we ended up coming fifth so from that
one week you know we wanted to turn a
corner in 2015 and that's when Glenn
Glenn Moore and Wesley Clark and uh
Reuben Samuels kind of came in and and
that that can a Canada trip was was
awesome
um there was a series over there that we
we were really successful and we played
really good rugby um so there was a good
massive change in point for us so in
terms of a whole year that year was
probably one of one of my favorites
um but nothing will probably we beat the
2017 World Cup final
you know after losing 2014 we were going
to that World Cup and we weren't coming
home without it
um and then to I think you know we were
down at half time I just remember
sitting in there obviously a different
coaching group then the slight change we
had Grant Keenan come in as coach and he
was our backs coach and I just remember
sitting in the in the changing room at
half time and
hey guys to me um you know he's going
through what what he what what he's seen
and what we need to kind of look at for
the second half and I remember sitting
there and everyone was kind of sitting
there with like just in real I guess
real Focus there was no there was real
quiet it was quite a little bit unusual
but and then I remember coming up to me
Grant comes up to me and goes kinch
you're all good like you know same
yourself you're right and I said don't
worry we've got this it's almost like we
all knew that what we needed to do and
we just needed that time to to process
what we needed to do and as soon as we
ran out we just flipped the game over
completely and we were playing a white
expensive game but um England knew that
so we started to play a tighter game and
just I think for me it was around the
ability as a as a team to to be able to
do that to flick that switch over and
change a game plan completely which was
probably almost never heard of in the
women's game Jimmy at that time
um so it was pretty special to come in
and now our prop scored a hat trick tock
um scored a hat trick and a World Cup
final and you know we have extra brisky
enough Telly doing Crossfield Cooks you
know like there was just that to me was
a big change in in the women's game as
well and how it was played and we set a
really high standard there so you know
when you can remember a game that
clearly
um that's obviously you know it's
definitely a special one special one for
me yeah
love that and you what are your nerves
like going into a World Cup final you're
nervous sort of player and obviously
you've got the goal kicking duties as
well which always adds a little bit more
pressure especially in a World Cup final
yeah yeah I um I used to be I used to be
really nervous and
um you know I couldn't eat a lot you
know I guess the day of the game and I
think I you know you get me into a skill
support and help around dealing with
that and
um I think just experience has helped me
now
um but if I don't get nervous that's
when I I find that there's an issue
um you know nerves and excitement is the
same sensation that's how I look at it
like you just feel a little bit on your
stomach and you're like man that's just
because I'm excited it's you know you
know people see nerves as a bad thing
but it's not um you probably know that
as a player too to me when you played um
you know you you've got to embrace that
and for me as a goal kicker and you know
we had a session with DC the other day
and he said you know you've got to have
a purpose of you know a reason why you
kick and my purpose is literally because
I just love the pressure
um I thrive on it um so for me I I want
to take those kicks to win the game
um you know so that's the reason why I
kind of I love goal kicking and and you
know I think I've kind of taught myself
to control my nerves and control you
know I've got a lot of things going into
a game
um from the training week into the water
into Captain's run into the walkthrough
on the game day and then you know you go
through the The Anthem and then it's a
hakka then it's a game so there's a lot
of moments within the game you've got to
be out of control where you can your
emotions if you need to
um you know and there's some girls and
even myself and when I was 19 day Bowen
I bored my eyes out on the anthem I just
couldn't control it and and I guess the
good thing for me as I was going
straight to the bench after that to be
able to sit down and and relax
um but some girls on Davos start right
and they play so
um you know for me I just I think just
experiences help that so now I just I
thrive on on singing The Anthem I get up
for it um you know the one on the
weekend for my 58th test it was a little
bit of motion so holding back a few
tears but then you're going to slap from
it into a bit of a different mindset for
Haka and then you've got to flick again
into game mode so there's always little
moments that you've got to be able to
learn to control we've got a lot of
support systems and structures in place
now to support that which is cool have
you always been a goal kicker
uh yeah yeah I've always done it and
always loved it
um you know you've got those memories as
a kid
um well when you didn't have a tease
it's just drop kick and you used to live
you know after we come off the farm I
used to live across from the school so
I'd go home Chuck my bags down come back
down and have a run around and score
tries win World Cups you know need to
get this drop kick to to win the World
Cup and kick the ball into the trees
behind the posts and you know on wet
rainy days when you know my sisters were
inside probably reading books or doing
something else I'd be at scoring tries
and diving in the in the mud and in the
water and so I've just um from there
just told myself to be honest as well
I've taught myself how to goal kick I've
had a few lessons in the past but
um you know a few tips from from the
likes to Dan Carter or coaches and all
things like that but
um Hannah Porter was absolutely legend
of the game I remember her giving me
some key tips when I was a young black
Fern
um but I just taught myself how to do it
from a young imagine still finding ways
to improve too to be honest
so none of your sisters were into any of
that stuff they were like you said
inside girls and you were the one out
there getting stuck into the mouth it's
crazy because most I guess most women
players have older brothers or something
and they sort of get dragged along or
beaten up by their Bigger Brothers but
you've sort of done it all yourself
yeah we've got like what was I said it's
a heaps of girls they're in the team
that have got older brothers
um yeah but for me your three sisters
there they they are sporty though um
we're a very sporty family so you know
they've played netball basketball hockey
and all that through school
um I think my twin circular twin sister
um she tried to play rugby once and I
told her she wasn't allowed because it
was my sport so um
um you know so for me I was it was just
I just absolutely loved that I think
just because I kind of it was almost I
don't know any different right like I
was four years old when I picked up the
rugby ball and I was basically for Dad I
was the um you know his I guess his son
that he he never he never got you know I
was the one holding the spanner and
holding the you know holding things for
him when he was fixing stuff and grabbed
the hammer hold this and and almost
think back and I think how awesome that
is because I can change a tire um you
know I can do those small change of
Light by all those small things you know
because I was helping dad it kind of I
learned those Wiki key tips off him so
yeah is it's it's quite bizarre but you
know through
starting when I was four years old all
my mates were I was mates of the boys I
grew up with them
um you know if any of them picked on me
the you know mum and dad knew or whatnot
because we're all close family friends
um you know I had a had a mate uh
Matthew who on his door
um whatever no girls except Kendra
running on his door so I was the only
one that was out on his bed bedroom so
um you know so for me and then I went to
an all-girl School mate so that was a
massive change for me going into year
nine
um having lots of boy boy you know boy
mates and boyfriends into having
um to you know find some from a
different group of friends yeah and how
was that
yeah I mean I guess the cool thing was
to start with as I am my twin sister on
you know in the first couple of days but
we're so different we basically had two
days together and then we just went off
with our different groups of mates
um but being sporty helps their day like
it's so much easier to to find friends
and you know that my school friends are
my lifelong friends we're still mates
today
um majority of them are still in the
necky when I go home
um you know over Christmas or anytime I
go home and catch up with them and
um you know they've always been hugely
supportive of of my Rugby as well and
you know I had a couple of them at the
game and the weekend and
um yeah no it was it was definitely
different
um I had to to learn a bit and you know
I guess be a bit different but um no
it's it's been cool because I still have
some really good boy you know boy mates
as well which is awesome love there and
you mentioned like 2015 being one of
your favorite years and individually for
you you had a lot of and you won a lot
of awards that year two you won the best
player in the world as best female
player in the world and in New Zealand
as well what did you put that year down
to individually being so good
um well I think for me was probably
um you know I Emma Jackson I said my
Emma gents and the other half back for
for nine years
um you know so I sat in the saddle I was
patient I worked on my craft I did what
I needed to do as well as trying to help
her you know prepare her for every game
um so that year was my opportunity there
was the year when I got my first you
know got that consistently of starting
every test so for me it was I was given
the opportunity and when that came I
just wanted to take it with with two
hands and I think that's what it just
came down to is I'd done the hard graft
of of sitting in the you know in the
back seat and soaking it all in so that
I always told myself when you get the
opportunity you need to take it with
both hands and and that's what I did and
you could see it in my game I bought a
different kind of style game to what
Emma Jensen did and
um and it worked for us and you know I
think now
um I started every test since 2015 so I
wasn't just my first 58th test in the
weekend was my 50th consecutive test for
the team as well and
um so I started all those tests since
then and so I was thinking about that
last night I didn't actually realize
until I was thinking I was like oh [ __ ]
I've actually started since 20 2015 so
and that's just every year year and year
out I just want to be the best I want to
be the best aspect in the world I'm
hugely competitive
um sometimes it can be be an issue when
you're doing stuff or training back at
home with your with our Hub and that but
um everyone knows it's because I'm
competitive and it's for the best
interest
um but that's probably what it comes
down to is that just the opportunity is
going to take it otherwise your mind
would ever come again so so nine years
you were you didn't get a chance to
start is that right
yeah I think I started one game in the
in the World Cup
um and then the others was just yeah
sitting in there and I'd probably you
know your first on you start maybe
getting five minutes off the beach
because you never used to really use the
bench back when I started you only kind
of used it a few injured so
um if there was injury sorry so yeah and
then I just sat there and then I got
started to get you know 10 minutes and
then 15 minutes and then 20 minutes and
probably 20 minutes was the maximum I
would have would have got
um and then yeah now I'm the one playing
the the 60 the 65 minutes
um yeah so it's quite bizarre but I feel
like I did my time
um and you know credit to Emma Jensen
too um you know she we had a lot good
little wee healthy competition between
us and it was it was fantastic
it is a long time to
be sitting behind someone though isn't
it so is it um did you ever get to the
point where you're starting to run out
of patience or you're getting to the
point where you like I'm starting to
drop your lip a wee bit
yeah I guess probably the last um
probably 2013 2040 as um you know you
get ankle and you're like because you
you know you're starting you've been
there for a long time but at the same
time I absolutely loved it like I just
loved any any opportunity I got on the
Jersey and just just took that bit you
know I'd be lying if I said I didn't get
impatient
um because you know that's that's just
not the reality of it and
um you know I knew email was coming to
the end of her career as well so I just
had to keep telling myself just just be
patient in there soak it all up Learn
learn from her learn from the likes to
Anna Richards who was who was my 10
um and then towards the end he started
you know I don't say I wouldn't have
said I would drop my bottom lip but it
was a point where you know you get to a
point where you're like man I probably
feel I should be starting over over here
but it comes down to the coaching group
and and you know and how and who they
select so I just had to you know buy my
time and continue and then yeah 2015 new
Bex coach kind of come in and and that's
when I got that start over over here
um she ended up playing that year and
then after that she she retired and then
instantly that first year getting your
first year to start and then
at the end of that year become being
named the best player in the world
what's what's that feeling like
holy like just you uh
whatever
so that was
2015 was awesome it was over at the
world rugby Awards in in London
um obviously there's the world cup over
there the men's World Cup so
um I just remember going to the water
they fly you over
um especially I went to the World Cup
final it's when the ball Black's been
Aussie
um and then the awards night was the
next night and I just remember sitting
there and watching and just soaking it
all up and then it got to my award and
you know you kind of get a little bit
nervous and you're going oh my gosh like
I'm not going to win this like there's
so many other amazing players out there
and then my name got called out and I
was just like
am I a what like I was actually in shock
for a minute like I was sitting there
and then I had a couple of mates there
with me because they were traveling the
world at the time so I invited one of
them to to come along with me and she's
like your name got called out you need
to go up and then from there I was just
like telling myself not to trip over I
was like don't trip over Dash if I were
I was like because you know you kind of
see what what way people go up the
stairs and see how they walk across and
I just never want to be that person that
shoves over so that's all that was going
through my head I was shaking at this at
the time
um and Maggie Alfonso who was a legend
of England so I um she was giving out
the award and you know she she presented
me with it and at the same time
um all the All Blacks stood up because
they were all there and gave me a
standing ovation so that was the thing
that all I could remember was them
standing up as I was walking up on the
right side and me telling myself don't
trip over Dutch trip over
um but it all kind of happened so
quickly
um and then just after coming off this
stage at the other end holy heck it was
nuts with the media like it just went
crazy all the things I had to do and get
into and
um being yeah being so young in it but
it was such an amazing event they put on
a pretty pretty good event as you could
imagine and then after that came home
and then a few months later was
nominated for a New Zealand player of
the women's player of the year so to get
the Glad Rags on again and dress up and
then won that
which was which is probably pretty cool
and pretty special for me my dad had
just been diagnosed with cancer
um and so he he then was going through
chemo and all that kind of stuff so I
guess to win that just kind of helped
the family and and you know get them
kind of through that and he's you know
he's in remission now obviously and he's
he's fought it and I don't know just
things like that it kind of just helps
helps I guess keep the family going and
all that so I was pretty special in
2015. we're confident going into that
New Zealand one once you've been named
World Player of the Year surely you're
going to be the best in New Zealand is
that what you're thinking
no no well I it kind of crosses your
mind now you're like oh maybe but then I
know someone I know someone that won the
world rugby one and didn't win the New
Zealand one so someone had told me that
because they were like oh surely you're
going to want it short and I was like oh
maybe we'll just see what happens and
then and then I got told yes someone won
the world rugby one I'm not the New
Zealand so then that put me back in my
seat just to be like okay just tell
yourself you might not win this
but another award I may be winning is
the um 2018 New Zealand player of the
year so this was a men and women you're
going the list with the likes of Bowden
bear Kieran Reid Richie McCaw all the
legends of the game what was it like
winning this one this must have been
unreal yeah that one holy heck I'll
never forget that one either
um kind of same situation I got my my
twin sister I just stepped into because
I try and invite you know the family
who's available so mum and dad had
already been to one and this next one I
was like oh take take my twin sister you
know get get her to come up talking and
and go and so she was with me and and um
and I mean I can't agree Canary coach
was nominated for coach of the year
because we had won consecutive fire
Palmer cups then as well so
um yeah just sitting there again
um and I had one a few or pharmaceuti
medal which is the FBC player of the
year so sitting there at one net so I'd
already had to go up on stage and then
the night kind of went on and I just
remember
um because I won New Zealand Player of
the Year as well so the one sorry New
Zealand women's player of the year so I
went up on stage and I knew the Kelvin
Tremaine one was the next award after
that so I remember going up on stage and
getting the woman's player of the year
and I was um there was a seat there and
just just one seat and then sasumo was
interviewing me for that and
um because then I do all two Awards and
then you'd go down off the stage after
that and then the guy from sky
he comes up to me at the end after
everyone was clipping he goes oh I need
to put this seat here for the next Award
winner so then my mind was I haven't won
this award because why I'm already up on
stage and there's obviously someone
coming up to sit in the seat next to me
so I'm already sitting on stage right
um and then you know names are getting
called out from the AVS and I don't know
I guess the world we were living in to
me it was like holy heck a female's
never going to win this award
um you know if things will get obviously
getting better in the game and the
woman's game was more supportive but I
just remembered 2010 when the All Blacks
won Team of the Year over us when we had
won the World Cup and they had only won
the bled
um you know so that was in the back of
my mind I was like oh you know you've
been nominated for it you know I was
pretty stuck just to to be nominated for
it and I just remember sitting there and
there's a screen
um down on the stage that me and Sumo
were watching and then
um they're going through the nominees
and then then my name got called out and
I just again I was just like got my
stomach dropped and I was just like
what the heck and then you kind of look
around and look out to the crown you
can't see anything because a lot the
lights are like bright in your eyes
um and I was so so blown away I just
started shaking
um started shaking and again started
telling myself when I get up don't trip
over the chair like because Grant
Robertson
um was giving out the the award and so I
had to you know get up off my chair go
around and give them a hug and get the
award and again just telling myself
don't trip over just be careful of your
surroundings you know
um and I remember him Grant Robertson
when he presented it to me he said this
is real heavy so I had to like just make
sure I was tensing so it wasn't the old
here it is and then you know dropped
forward
um yeah don't want to draw Flat so um
yeah he gave it to me and then I went
and sat back down and I just needed like
it was good because Sumo I know Sumo
very well
um and he was giving me a couple of
times just to take a couple of deep
breaths but at the same time I knew he
was trying to make me cry when he was
interviewing me and I'm like top look
was like shaking and I was my whole body
was shaking and I'm trying to hold
myself together and yeah far out it was
you know pretty special moment and then
got back to my seat or same thing with
the media a lot of media around it and
then got back to my seat to see my my
twin sister and everybody like it took
me probably an hour to get back from
from um you know after after getting off
stage back to my seat to to see my
sister and and everyone at my table but
um because I was just getting stopped
the whole time and then you know I was
getting messages my phone blew up
um you know I was breaking news New
Zealand Herald breaking news that I'd
won the Kelvin Tremaine and yeah far out
it was unbelievable and yeah pretty
surreal time I'm just reflecting back on
it now I'm probably getting more
emotional now
but um I just I got back to my twin
sister and she was crying I'm like why
are you crying like
um
but yeah it was pretty cool way like
just you know that smashing you know I
guess glass ceilings making history no
one ever done it before and for me it
was about what I'd done for the women's
game
um that's what I reflect back on now
look at her as like holy heck I I've won
that I've put women's rugby on there you
know at the top
um and you know young girls are going to
see this and I want a spider to be a
black Fern or to play rugby and that was
what was pretty special for me too 100
inspiring so many and pretty fair to say
that you're never going to trip up
receiving an award you've got so much
awareness around it
when you watch so many awards of Grammys
in there don't even see things like I do
not want to do that sorry I should just
do it now I just for a joke
deliberate yeah it's pretty good stuff
yeah
oh but we do need to crack on I don't
want you to be late to the um your first
meeting ever but
um what are your plans going forward
obviously you've got the Rugby World Cup
you are getting to the end of your
career any plans
yeah I mean I think that the biggest
focus is I'm just you know being in the
career and I was having a good chat with
with um Dan Carter about it the other
day like you know talking about how did
you know that it was time
um what was your process you went
through and all that kind of stuff so it
was really cool I'm just starting to to
talk to a lot of players around it and I
keep getting told that you know you're
retired a long time and I think
um around the woman's game with opeci
now
um you know I had covered during that
and only played one game am I happy with
that
um I won 94 games for Canterbury you
know I've got this all these things that
are kind of sit in there but my main
focus at the moment is I'm just trying
to I'm just tell myself and I'm a real
planned person so for me to I guess I'm
just trying to live day by day now like
I just want to enjoy every moment
um this whole time being in this camp at
the moment just getting up and enjoying
the game and love you know checking on
the black jersey with my mates and and
representing my country I just want to
enjoy and and that's what's been really
good for me is I probably the last
couple of years I got called into a lot
of structure and a lot of stuff off the
field as a leader that was going on and
now I feel free again so it's what's
been really cool is I can I can be free
and play you know play free rugby again
too which is which has been really cool
um but then yeah from here we've got a
few try we've got a trial match coming
up we've got a couple of
um games against Australia for the Lorry
O'Reilly and then then there's the Big
World Cup right so the the end goal for
the year is for me to to be peaking the
time the World Cup comes around and be
selected for for that side
um and I'm I'm trying not to think too
far past that yet
um that's the big The Big Goal but yeah
you know I guess 30 years of playing the
game 16 years and the black Fern's in a
high level
um there would be no better way to end
my career than winning a World Cup for
Eden Park on home turf
um so that's what's that's what been
pretty cool off that we can we can
achieve that I'd probably look at what
my plans might be for for next year
um but I always give back to the game
Jimmy like I I work for New Zealand
Rugby well I have in the past obviously
we're full-time black ferns now but
um I would work in the women's
participation space so trying to get
more girls and women into the game and
um I always go back to rugby because
what it's given me and I think
um I'll you know I might get into
coaching as well post post this I want
to give all my experience and knowledge
back to the back to the game
um pretty Keen to potentially go around
and be a kicking coach for a woman and
girls as well so there's got these other
little things that I I want to start
kind of planning but I don't want to put
too much into because I just want to
focus on getting through through this
year
um and you know talking to DC too I was
like you know how did you know and he's
like oh I just wanted to enjoy you know
my years of playing and what rugby had
kind of given him and he said don't want
to be like clinging on you know just and
you know so I'm not Clinging On You so
um that's what's been really cool so
we'll see how how the next six months go
uh and then we'll probably make a bit of
a plan a bit of a plan from there
um post post yeah I do have a bit of a I
have a bit of a fear about what rugby is
going to be and what life's going to be
post rugby because it's been what 30
consecutive years of playing the game
like I've got to put plans and bits and
pieces in place because I've got
finished and I'll be like holy heck what
do I do now
um but you know there's small things
like I want to go snowboarding I want
you know I want to try so many things
that I haven't been able to do because
of rugby
um so I've just started to put things in
place and you know I might move to play
some indoor netball you know like
playing squash again I used to play
Squash so just doing things that I
haven't done for a long time which uh
yeah might get rolled the arm over
hopefully Ted slips me for black cash
again
yeah just stuff like that so we'll see
ya see how it fans out exciting times
and hearing you talk about the World Cup
mates getting me super pumped about
finding a Eden Park Rugby World Cup oh
exciting times but we have I have gone
to the Instagram for some questions and
heaps have come through so I won't be
able to ask them all for the people
who've sent them in but
um we'll fly through a couple of these
uh first question fastest Bronco time
oh um my fastest Bronco I ran a 458
um that was a very long time ago that
was when I was in the sevens uh back in
like 20 2013 2014.
um which is which is pretty good for us
sub five in the women's games you know
everybody awesome
um but I tend to sit around 5 10 5 10 5
15 in there who does the quickest one
sister
uh we had Kelly Kelly Brazier and
Slicker waniada have did the two
quickest that I've had in the 15th game
around I think a 4 45 or something
ridiculous nice yeah
okay you've mentioned Dan Carter a few
times he's also jumped in with a
question here Andy Alice or Wayne Smith
that's a great question
so I I spent a lot of years with Andy
who him give it you know taking me for
some sessions and kind of mentoring me
slightly so and smoothie I've only had
for three months yeah um but holy heck
they've both got some amazing knowledge
um you know they're both awesome people
and like almost quite similar actually
they're really similar they could almost
be like Father and Son those two
um I haven't said that to Smoothie yet
but
um they'll post quite you know quite
intense they're both love it and they're
both so passionate
um so I'll probably have to go just with
Andy because he's been he's been very
awesome to me over the years fair enough
like that one okay next one how do you
think you'd go on a Bunnings Cup game
oh
um far out
I think my password probably to be too
slow and at that level
um now I I think I'd be able to I think
I'd be fast I think I'd be able to get
to the rucks and deliver the balls 10
might have to be a bit closer
um but let's just hope that I wouldn't
have to make any taggles
oh I'd be good to say it I'd be yeah I'd
love to see that yeah imagine that
yeah I'm probably too old for that now
Jimmy
okay Nick so this is a good one best
advice to it best advice to a dad
supporting his daughter in her sporting
aspirations
I guess for me is just allowing allowing
your allowing allowing her to do what do
her
um you know I think there's there's been
so much pressure that have been that's
been put on from parents in the in the
past and for me my parents never put any
pressure on me it was just about being
the best I could be and I know there's
times I know that Dad would have been
um he would have been like oh my gosh
these guys like give her the ball
um or you know some issues with I've had
a couple issues with some coaches in the
past because I played the same position
as their son
um but just being hugely supportive back
in her when she needs someone to talk to
someone to
um you know just being positive you know
positive imagine positive around the
game
um and just um I guess getting her to
set some goals actually as well
um is always a good one and and helping
her through those but just yeah the
biggest thing is not putting any
pressure and if she plays other sports
allow her to do that I'm here to round
balance is better I've played like six
or seven Sports at school and I think
that's what's allowed me to become the
player I am today so
um and if she gets the opportunity take
it with two hands because it might only
ever come once great advice love that
one great answer and good question for
whoever sent that in
um next two more questions this next
question is from our major sponsor swish
which I know you're on swish so if you
are listening go get a swish from Kendra
one of the great swishes in the world uh
if you could get a video shout out from
any celebrity who would it be and why
hmm
I would say do you know what this is
gonna make people laugh I absolutely
love Celine Dion
yeah like she's nice is this one person
she's in my um I'm like my game day
playlist uh but also Simone biles I
think I think Simone biles is an
absolute freak
um you know like gymnasts I think that
would be pretty cool
um to be able to get a message from her
so swish if you can make that happen
that'll be awesome
let's make it happen how does your swish
go yet constantly doing them oh
yeah there's a I've only had I've only
had a couple who haven't been on it too
long
um just a couple but um I'm the one that
you know I get asked for messages and
that all the time and from you know from
kids or four teams and that and I just
tend to just flick one through
um when I can and to support them
wherever I can too so but um what a cool
platform especially like holy heck I've
seen a lot of their videos on there and
that's the reactions from people getting
videos from you know from actual
celebrities is pretty cool yeah it's
awesome stuff okay last question best
piece of advice you have for a woodland
listener
oh
um the best piece of advice
would be to continue to listen to what
alert because Jimmy's going to have a
lot of females jump on on now
breaking the trend you're a trendsetter
just like the award now on the podcast
Breaking Traditions it's just breaking
glass ceilings
um I think for me is they're nice and I
think for me advice would just be um
I've probably kind of said it is
um you know is allowing allowing people
to be themselves
into if there's any ever an opportunity
to do something that you love
um do it and never be told that you
can't there's a few times through
through my career I was told I couldn't
play with the boys but there was no
reason for it so I did it anyway so
um and just yeah enjoying enjoying the
moment
um where you can and I guess Life's too
short so embrace it
love that oh we do need to get more
women on this podcast that is powerful
stuff I love it
I really appreciate you coming on the
podcast it's been awesome to hear your
journey
um obviously you are an absolute
inspiration to all the female rugby
players out there especially the young
ones who are looking to make a pathway
through the game as well and obviously
still inspiring a lot of men players as
well so it's been awesome to hear how
your story's gone and um really excited
for the Rugby World Cup I I cannot wait
to see the black Ferns and yourself
competing at this Rugby World Cup but I
really appreciate you coming on the
podcast awesome thanks Jimmy thanks for
having me it's been an awesome chat in
to you and I appreciate appreciate for
you know you for having me on the on the
show and being the first female so
hopefully you get a couple more
listeners you're a legend appreciate it
cool thanks Jeremy see you later
[Music]
[Music]